Nicole is in Cincinnati ain't Nicole how
are you hi dad I'm so excited to talk to
you you too what's up
okay I'm hoping you can settle an
argument between my husband and I I'm a
professional argument settler not really
but I'll try what's up okay so um my
husband and I don't have any debt we no
no school loans no car payments no
mortgage nothing like that but we have
pretty much no emergency savings right
now I think there's like $1 45 in that
account it's pretty sad I currently and
making 42 after taxes give or take some
overtime my husband he took off of work
this past summer because he was in
school we're paying for all of his
school out of pocket and in the last
couple weeks we've gotten really serious
about starting to save up for emergency
fund and get our finances back in order
so they're no longer controlling us
we're kind of controlling them good and
Georgia blue the argument is I get paid
monthly so we were going to use this
first paycheck in October to get our
first thousand dollars in the bank baby
step one and beyond that we're going to
try and get our three to six months of
expenses and as quickly as possible my
husband has gone back to work and he's
got some just temporary work while he's
in school right now good what's the
argument the argument is she wants to
buy the new iPhone she's gotta be
kidding he'd lose and he loses I don't
even need to hear this don't you have no
money you don't I don't buy a freaking
iPhone 6 when you don't have an
emergency fund that's what I said this
is called being grown up here no no no
no no no and by the way and by the way
you don't go by a $600 purse either
while you don't have an emergency fund I
don't buy person I know or whatever
whatever it is that you like right I
mean there's nothing wrong with the
iPhone 6 I already got one
I'm their kind of cool that's fine but
whoopee but I got the money I'm not
broke you guys are broke so get yourself
not broke you got a plan here you know
exactly what you're supposed to be doing
he knows that too doesn't he yeah I
think so
I mean really you guys are working your
butts off to get him through school
you're doing all this stuff smart you've
got the money saved and now you don't
have an emergency fund and you committed
to have an emergency fund and then Apple
steps in and says you need a new iPhone
no way
okay wait yeah what kind of phone is he
got right now he's got the previous
iPhone the five yes it works just fine I
had one of those good and it'll work
fine for a couple more years I don't
mind him getting a six when you're not
broke okay you just don't you don't pick
gadgets over the over the security of
your family thank you epic loss he
didn't just lose it's not your input
yeah I'm gonna get my I put on my Dave
Ramsey striped shirt and blow the
whistle out-of-bounds personal foul
ejected from the game epic loss thank
you very much Dave thanks for the call
oh my gosh
you